when Hilary Duff saying this is what
dreams are made of she was talking about
she knows if I put my hot cheetos in the
freezer because I like them cold
I'm Tyler and we have hot cheetos here I
personally love hot cheetos because i
eaten them since elementary school I'm
David I'm a big fan of hot cheetos I've
loved him ever since I was in elementary
school and I'm Holly my personal
relationship with hot cheetos is I eat a
bag a day at least
I'm DJ I love hot cheetos they are by
far my favourite snack in the world I
eat them every day
and I'm never gonna stop mood so fun
little facts about what you're eating
you know you read am I gonna be sad
after I know I can't use this hand
because I'm not trying to get rid of
anything this health professionals have
likened people's love for salty
processed snacks like flamin hot cheetos
to an addiction to illicit substances
because a growing body of research
suggests with the brains response to
both items is very similar for some the
brain may actually release feel-good
chemicals
in response to eating a favorite snack
like hot cheetos I feel that the
chemical reaction in your brain is like
when you eat flaming hot cheetos all the
time is the same for when you do drugs
I like having an addiction we could just
switch you know right they make it you
know the burning red pooop' and all that
kind of stuff but it's better than
destroying their bodies from the drugs
I assume that's what's going on here so
hey we've philanthropists people who
help people scientific employer the
spicy snack has also induced trips to
the hospital because overeating them can
cause upper abdomen and chest pains
medical professionals have recommended
that those with the history of gastro
esophageal reflux avoid eating hot
cheetos because they can induce acid
reflux and heartburn we don't blame the
Cheetos for that you're over here I had
acid reflux as a kid
and I've been recently getting chest
pains out and I noticed that there after
eating hot cheetos but you know I eat a
ton Senor fine and you have something
that you can barely pronounce going on
with you I don't think you should be
eating IG does when richard month ania's
came up with the idea for flamin hot
cheetos he was working as a janitor at
frito-lay plant month Anya's is the son
of a Mexican immigrant and at different
points in his childhood lived in a
migrant labour camp as well as a
one-bedroom apartment with his parents
and ten siblings he says he was inspired
by Mexican a lavash sold by street
vendors now he's an executive with
PepsiCo hey you got rocky and then you
got Richard Montaigne according to food
scientists even with with Hurley Cheetos
exhibit a phenomenon called vanishing
caloric density that essentially tricks
your brain into believing you're not
consuming as many calories as you really
are when foods break down quickly in
your mouth oh yes there's a lie there I
know how much I'm eating is in the bag I
don't know about you you're so much but
my stomach can handle it unless ya 330
right here Thank You Friedel a flamin
hot cheetos contains small amounts of
red 40 Lake and yellow six Lake food
dyes both of which are approved for use
in the US but have been found to contain
that is a Dean and other carcinogens
according to the Center for Science in
the Public Interest the safety of these
dyes hasn't been adequately tested I
mean when you flaming hot cheetos you're
playing with fire we already know that
that hasn't died yet
I think we're fine Khan says we don't
know what it does yet so I don't know
why I should stop eating harmless good
BR tell me otherwise does not rule that
out
I'm here for a good time not real long
time eating large quantities of flamin
hot cheetos has been known to make poop
appear red or orange due to the red food
dye in the product and burn
I've known this lady hot I definitely
had some occult sirs from eating them I
would get rushes of pains like randomly
and I'm pretty sure pretty sure it's my
hot cheetos not judging by my
consumption of these at all America I'm
sorry you don't yeah it really doesn't
my mom sends me articles daily my dad
sends me warnings I'm like wow that's
how I feel that's my two cents two cents
with Dave Dave's last two cents
[Music]